is happening in the generative AI space
so you should be you should be uh
getting some understanding of that also
the more that you can get will be better
so large language models generative AI
chat GPT you must be using a lot I hope
uh so prompt engineering is not
something which which which might uh
might be very difficult to pick up uh
it's very simple to understand and you
can pick it up very fast uh and then AI
strategy and Consulting overall will be
kind of a blanket term which you can use
for all these things and uh and and uh
even when you talk about from Big Data
technology perspective I have seen lot
of work is happening at the AIML layer
of Big Data where you're trying to build
applications which is distributed across
the across the clusters of big data that
we talk about but again underlying part
would be a sound understanding of of uh
the the machine learning and deep
learning uh algorithms and back that up
with the with the mlops so if you ask me
I would say focus on mlops go through
generative Ai and large language models
for sure and rest of the stuff would be
something like that that will fall in
place as you start going into that
particular
direction uh thank you so much aminda
for giving us an overview of the hottest
skills in IM space in
2014 uh someone is saying basically uh
your voice is not clear but it's pretty
much clear to me so uh maybe like uh for
other folks please do let us know in
case the voice is not Audible for our
speaker we'll just uh do a quick check
here and also as we have talked about
the skills here let's talk about the uh
training career paths which will be in
demand in 2024 not only 2024 even today
2024 and future and Beyond as well sure
so so let's let's uh start with the data
engineering concept over here so data
Engineers are the one which will help
with the data pipelines that we talk
about so people who who have hor
understanding of of working with the
different types of databases data
structures and data warehousing Concepts
and then they can map those data points
to some kind of analysis which needs to
be carried out that's where data
Engineers will come into the picture
they're pretty useful uh in terms of uh
uh helping data scientist ml engineers
in getting the right data building the
entire Pipeline and making sure that
everything is working uh uh swiftly
that's what data Engineers will be doing
so mostly on the data front you need to
work then you have this uh machine
learning engineer if I talk about they
should have good understanding of
machine learning Concepts and their
their primary role would be in terms of
uh easing out the development and the
deployment process so they should also
know how to work with the different ml
Ops techniques which are there different
different mlops platforms it could be
say Docker kuber Q flow ml flow all
these these tools uh or or not all these
then probably some of the tools they
should be aware of so their primary role
would be to build machine learning
pipelines which would be put in
production eventually and that as I
mentioned they should have some tool
knowledge some some some algorithm
knowledge then you have say artificial
intelligence domain when you're talking
about AI researcher AI developers so
primary if you talk about AI researcher
that's more on on the side of of of
experimenting with the new Concepts
dealing with the with the research which
is going on across the Globes checking
out which which will fit in a particular
uh opportunity that that as an
organization we have and and trying to
explore that more so that is on more on
a research side and that is basically uh
it will involve with working with the
newer Concepts which is happening in the
in the field of deep learning machine
learning and uh of course you should
have sound knowledge of of all these
Concepts prior to moving to that
particular
job role and you should also learn how
to how to do experimentation with
different tools AI developer uh which
which is basically we talking about
someone who can who can develop end to
endend uh ai ai applications so
basically taking a particular problem
then designing the entire entire
pipeline desig designing the entire
architecture and eventually developing
it is what AI developer would be doing
then you have data science uh the reason
I'm taking it in the last because data
scientist is something which which
people most of the people want to become
a data scientist so data scientist is
someone who is actually who has good
knowledge of of of of programming
programming languages some of the pro
not all of them like probably couple of
them you should pick up uh python is is
the front runner in that so you have
good understanding of programming
languages and then you have very very
sound knowledge of of statistical
modeling machine learning in modeling
within machine learning framework you
pretty good at uh uh different machine
learning algorithm as well as deep
learning algorithms you know how to take
a particular problem how to solve it how
to experiment with it you know how to
find youe a particular model that you
are building you can you you you also
ready to explore new OP new new models
which are coming into the market so you
keep uh keep updating yourself on the on
the job so that's something what data
scientists would be doing so this is how
you can think of different job roles
which are there in this particular
field sorry also as you were speaking uh
we actually asked folks you know which
AIML career path are you aspiring for in
2024 as well uh I think we've gotten few
respones well nain basically wants to be
a data scientist Abdullah wants to be a
machine wants to basically be machine
learning expert uh and then a wants to
be a data scientist and uh I can see
others as well please please feel free
to uh spam the chat with your career
paths I'm pretty sure you're here
because you're interested in IM IML or
already are basically studying IML or
aspiring for a career inl as we have
discussed a few of these uh trending
basically careers uh which basically no
one can you know replace as of now we
could love to know from these career
paths which you see on your screen here
which one would you want to take up in
2024 so uh let's let do a little bit of
visual thinking here and uh as the new
year is basically almost uh nearby so as
I I see that a lot of demand for ML
engineer data scientist and U Shin says
either AI researcher or ml engineer AI
developer is very much in demand as
well Abasi is currently studying DS
that's great uh awesome awesome uh folks
uh I think dasali has asked uh an
interesting question here uh which one
is the best for next 10 years the shali
wants to be safe uh and wants to decide
accordingly so what what would you
suggest
am next 10 15 years if you talk as a
field as an entire field itself AI
itself is is growing with a rapid pace
so anything that you pick up in this
particular domain will be will will have
a pretty good opportunity in next 10 15
years it's not that within AI something
will will die out in in sometime it's
not going to happen but uh probably if
you ask probably some of the machine
learning terms might be automated going
forward so I would say that focus on on
on the development part deployment part
so that's what I keep saying mlops is
pretty important and uh and uh towards
the Deep learning uh uh models that
you're talking about now we have the
technology like we are talking about uh
uh new gpus which are coming they're so
powerful and and like I other day I was
checking about Nvidia a00 and and and
h00 they have gone to a different level
all together so lot of lot of
experimentation we can do on a large
amount of data large scale data and also
complex models which is which is where
these large language models are actually
doing pretty well so what I'm trying to
tell you here is that going forward you
should uh you should learn such
technology which will help you in doing
distributed computing where Ai and ml
model is getting distributed towards
different on on different nodes
computers getting trend on the edge
devices and all so so that's what you
can focus upon so I would say that learn
a ml Concepts and start learning how you
can do the parallelized operation or
distributed computing that's what you
should you should think about but having
said that it doesn't mean that uh it
doesn't mean that uh uh some of the some
of the component some of the field
within AI would would would Sease to
Sease to exist in near near future so
anything that you pick up is for sure
going to last for 10 15 years but within
that you might look at something which
has more potential and that's what I
told
you great thank you so much amindra for
answering that the sh and others I hope
that answers your question please do let
us know if you have any follow questions
also in the Q&A box it will be very hard
to find in the chat box as you can see a
lot of messages are basically popping up
there so as you have talked about the
skills here as we have talked about the
career paths uh which will be trending
uh in 2024 and Beyond as well so let's
start with the interview prep uh hottest
questions you know in interview
basically you you basically a student
can face a potential candidate can face
in an AIML interview so uh let's start
with the first one here as you can see
uh so uh why basically a question which
get gets asked a lot is this one why did
you choose AIML as your career path as
I'm asking you this I would love to know
from the audience as well on the chat as
well why are you basically
choosing
yeah am I audible yes S I thought you
were asking others yeah others as well
yeah definitely so so if you ask me this
question why did you choose AIML as a
career path basically I would say that
or probably if I if I can give you some
point is think this way that uh what you
want to present over there that you are
very keen at problem solving you like uh
taking a complex problem and breaking
down into smaller component so first of
all you need to start by expressing your
genuine interest in the field of AI and
ml that's what you have to do and for
that if you want to share a brief
personal story or experience that
sparked your curiosity
or and and fascination with with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning that would be pretty good
actually like example I could say I have
always been captivated by the idea of
machine learnings learning and and
making Intelligent Decisions and my
interest in AIML began during uh during
my tenure at at a particular Bank when I
joined and where I realized that the
transformative power of these
Technologies and how banking was getting
entirely transformed at that point in
time which caught my eye and I started
my I started thinking that what all lies
ahead in this particular field and and
that's how I started and then then you
can also if you want you can highlight
your highlight the relevance to your
background if you have any like connect
your interest in AIML with your
educational background like I'm a stats
graduate so I can easily uh connect to
that or any previous experience you have
explain how your skills and background
align with the challenges and
opportunities presented by a IML like I
could say coming from a background in
statistics uh I saw AIML as a natural
progression and the ability to leverage
data for intelligent decision making uh
resonated with my passion for it so
that's what I could say or I can also
mention that that how the impact of AIML
on various Industries some examples I
can take that how I got very excited
when I heard that there will be
autonomous vehicles which which
basically
uh is is is based on object detection uh
as as one of the one of the component
and object detection is where the Deep
learning algorithms are coming into the
picture and that very idea that through
a video You're capturing images and
you're identifying objects correctly uh
was very interesting to me and I started
I started finding more about it and and
that's where I started uh uh noticing
that I have pretty good Keen interest in
this particular field so that's how you
can start with okay and and and and uh
if you are say
fresher uh if you're a fresher then you
can probably uh you can you can talk
about your academic background if you
can or you can talk about your Natural
Curiosity and eagerness to explore
Cutting Edge Technologies U mention any
self- learning initiative that you have
taken like you might have learned python
itself or you might have done some some
some project on it some online courses
you might have gone in the past so you
can start with that then you can also
you have to whether you're fresher or
not you have to have this problem
solving appeal so highlight the problem
solving aspect of AIML uh that appeals
to you like like you can say that you
know uh there were certain problems with
tradition with the traditional
approaches it was very difficult to
solve it could be it could be in
genomics it could be in say crime it
could be in in in in in banking
fraudulent transaction which was pretty
difficult to catch initially but with
the help of AIML it became easy and
that's where you start getting this
motivation that that you can solve some
some real time problem which was
traditionally difficult to solve some
complex problem and that's how your your
interest in started in this particular
uh uh field so so that way you can you
can frame it in in in a nice Manner and
probably ideally what you should do is
you should frame it write it properly
and practice and and then only you go
and and talk about it so many times what
happens is that you know the answer like
when somebody ask you why do you want to
choose this particular field probably
somewhere you know it but framing is
very important and that's where you have
to start jotting it down that what you
going to speak in what sequence that's
very important so knowing is one part
but putting across that in in in nice
manner in a nice articulate manner is is
a different thing all together so even
if you have the idea that why you want
to join just write it down that will
really help
you uh thank you so much amindra for
answering that uh question and also we
have gotten a lot of responses why
exactly folks want to choose AML as a
career uh also as we move on to the next
question here uh I have basically shared
on the chat here as well what is the
toughest interview prep question you
have faced or would want to know an
answer to uh basically how to answer it
you can let us know in the Q&A box we'll
take questions from there as well if you
get time so uh now let's move on to the
next question here and also this is for
you uh folks as well so can you describe
a specific IML project you have worked
on including the problem your approach
and the
outcome so this is pretty important
question actually what I see that when I
ask these questions in interviews and
what I have seen other otherwise also
that when when somebody's asked that
what kind of project you have worked
upon they simply answer like I did
object detection or we did a credit card
fraudulent transaction uh analysis so so
they tell that and they simply say that
we took data and we built a model or
probably little bit more on that but
what you need to understand over here is
that what interviewer is looking at is
is your your approach your your
understanding at different component of
machine learning life cycle so when you
are explaining this particular part that
what project you have worked upon or
what problem you have solved you have to
be very methodical and structured you
need to mention the entire life cycle
you might start with this that we have
we were given this particular problem
and state the objective and then explain
the relevant data that was there over
there don't just simply say the data was
given and then we cleaned it and then we
build the model and that's it you don't
have to answer like that you have to go
in detail of it which will showcase that
you have done it you understand the how
how the life cycle works you will go in
inside it like we had data at different
sources we picked up some data from my
SQL which was a Structure database and
then I had some unstructured data also
we combined that we integrated that
there were a couple of challenges over
there in integration you can mention
those challenges and how you sorted it
out then you go to the next level you
talk about data preparation and then you
can mention that data was huge it was a
complex data we had lot of ordinal
variables we had lot of category other
category nomin variables and for ordinal
we have too many too many levels so we
started grouping them at a higher level
or probably I started doing hashing or
whatever so what I'm trying to tell you
is that until unless you do not showcase
that at each level you have thorough
understanding explaining what project
you have done is of no use so go in
detail so you talk about data
preparation you can talk about data
transformation you can talk about
feature engineering you can exactly tell
what you have done in that then probably
you have done some kind of
dimensionality reduction explain why did
you do that and then you go to the model
building so then when I'm doing model
building probably I'm building a random
forest model so then first I need to
tell what all model I have tried so you
can explain that we I tried three three
model these three models and I picked up
say random Forest because it was giving
me a better result but within uh when
when I started working on it the model
was probably overfitted and I started
regularizing it and that's where I tried
different hyperparameter values I tried
kold cross validation and and a random
search uh algorithm to find the best set
of hyper parameter and then I did that
then I went to the evaluation stage I
evaluated the model further and I saw
model is going doing very well and that
I took as a baseline model is what you
need to explain that that was your
Baseline model after doing all these
things and then you went back to the
data again you started working again to
further fine tune the model what people
are doing I I see is that they simply
build a model they just try couple of
things at the hyper parameter tuning and
they stopped there what you need to do
is you need to explain to them that that
was something which I took as a baseline
then I started my experimentation again
and again after a number of iterations I
could I could improve the accuracy by
this much and that was my final model so
you need to explain entirely that this
was the problem this was the entire
approach I took and then you have to
start mapping that to an to to to a
particular business goal so this is what
the outcome is that once I I solve that
particular problem this is how it helped
the business or this is how how it was
beneficial entirely so that's how you
have to explain the project that you
have
done I hope this is making sense to all
of
you yeah uh thank you so much amindra
for answering this question uh in very
much detail please do let us know uh if
that basically uh answers your uh
basically your your questions as well
about doubts about this question uh I
see one response here it was great
prianka says and would love to know from
others as well and also any questions
you have for our speaker as well which
you would want to get answer let's move
on to the next one here now so the next
one here is can you discuss a
challenging problem you encountered in
your AML work and how you resolved it
one was what we were discussing
right
yeah uh and also U let's move on to the
next question here what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised
learning okay this also they ask a lot
and and another question that is asked
in in in in addition to these two terms
is semi-supervised learning so you talk
about supervised where you explain that
supervis learning is when you have the
label data and you can give some
examples whenever you're talking about
uh explaining a supervised learning do
not give examples only as regression and
classification as techniques give some
business example that when we are
solving this kind of problem that's a
supervised learning where we have this
sort of data and our objective would be
to predict a particular outcome that you
can mention there and similarly when
you're saying unsupervised learning you
mention unlabelled data yes clustering
is one one one example there anomaly
detection you can do but but then
explain that what kind problem it solves
so some business problem example also
you take it up what I have seen one more
thing is that people have good
understanding when when whever is
learning these terms they have good
understanding of what's supervised and
what's unsupervised it's the
semisupervised learning which is where
they get little confused in terms of uh
what the concept is and a a good
business example on that so so that you
need to that also you need to pick it up
you need to understand that what is a
good examle for semisupervised Learning
and you can take an example of Google
photos which is a very good example for
semisupervised learning Google photos is
a is a combination of supervised and and
unsupervised learning it's a
semi-supervised learning uh uh example
over there where you have a a small
portion of labeled data but lot of data
is unlabeled so pick up all these three
so you start with explaining that it's
trained on label data this is the
example this the the algorithms are
regression classification within that
you can mention
you have linear regression and you have
random Forest classifier random forest
regressor and all all those algorithms
give some example move to unsupervised
and if they ask about semi supervised
that also you can
answer okay thank you so much amra for
answering that question in so much
detail uh also uh let's move on to the
next question here for the interview
explain the concept of a decision Tree
in machine
learning okay if you get this question
or or for that matter any of the any of
the uh algorithm so if you have sound
knowledge then you can you can start
with with a technical answer that it is
it is starting with this like you you're
having a a node and then you're
branching it out at multiple levels so
you're kind of partitioning the data at
a different level and once you explain
this then you can also add over there
that in a simpler term what we are doing
over here is we are taking a problem and
then we are creating a kind of
conditional flow chart where we are
asking that if one particular property
has this value or that value or based on
a a logic which is say a guinea or
entropy that you are choosing we are
branching it out and eventually this is
how it is giving you the prediction what
I'm trying to tell you is that you give
the technical answer which is required
but you also add that in a very simpler
term this is what this is how it works
which gives you the that that gives the
idea that you have in-depth
understanding of of the
concept okay so so that's how you have
to explain now decision tree you can
mention that I can we do it for
for for classification and regression as
well but regression there is a there is
a disadvantage and you need to mention
what's the issue with the with the
decision Tre regression it doesn't
understand the linearity so you can
mention that although it can it is can
perform regression but it has some
disadvantage or it has some limitations
and this is what it is okay so this is
what you can mention over there and then
if they ask about uh one term is pruning
so why pruning is required so when when
it model is not generalizing well it's
it's overfitting then you go for then
you go for pruning so pruning again then
you have different types of pruning over
there okay so you have you have there uh
max depth you have minimum sample split
you have minimum sample Leaf you have
impurity there are so many things you
can do over there okay so so you you you
you should have good understanding of
those terms also because they might
there might be a followup question on
that so so this is what you should do I
would say that give a good definition
technical definition that you know like
the one which is mentioned here is a
flow flowchart like structure uh which
creates certain nodes and conditionally
we Branch out the data basically we
partition the data and we keep doing
until we left out with only similar
class of observation similar type of
observation and then we give the outcome
in a simpler term this is what it does
and if you can give with an example that
will be great like like generally in the
classroom I take example of of of a
bunch of people wants to go for a movie
and they are deciding in WhatsApp chat
so then it goes like this that uh what
time is the movie that's a very
important question because somebody
cannot come before six so that's a one
condition if the movie is after 6 yes I
can watch before 4 six no I cannot watch
I'm making the decision and then take
that idea and split at multiple question
there you have your decision tree so if
you explain like that it will give the
idea that you have good understanding
and that's how you're able to explain in
a simpler
term uh thank you so much amind for
answering this question in so much
detail uh we are getting a few uh good
questions in the chat and also in the
Q&A box as well uh but before we uh move
on to the Q&A part and also the prr
introduction we would love to know what
exactly is stopping you from becoming an
AIML expert so you can see a quick poll
uh which
is just launched on your screen
here just one second
please uh yes you can see a quick pull
launch on your screen here which says
what exactly is stopping you from
becoming ANL expert now this one is also
multiple choice question so you can
select multiple options here because
there can be mul multiple reasons right
multiple challenges which you're facing
as you're aspiring a career towards AML
now that you're here uh you're pretty
much interested inl which I saw from a
lot of your responses what careers are
you aspiring for inl so uh we would love
to know what exactly is the challenge
you're facing so this will uh give us a
good understanding of what are the
challenges you're facing or what's
stopping you from becoming an AML expert
in
2024 so I'll just read out these options
for you as a speaking I see respon
respes have already started coming in
for the poll uh but for the folks who
has yet to response uh so I just read
out those options for you so the first
one is I can't find a program with the
fully comprehensive curriculum second
one I don't have the Practical exposure
I need to become job ready third one I
find it difficult to learn from
prerecorded videos and the last one my
work schedule won't allow me enough time
for learning so uh these are the four
options here but in case this does not
cover your response you can let us know
on the chat or in the Q&A box as well
okay I'll just give five seconds more
for the poll here meanwhile uh folks
please utilize this time to put on uh
any questions you have uh for us so
we'll be moving towards the Q&A part as
well after the program preview so I
think last 5
Seconds uh for the poll here so five 4 3
1 let me quickly end the poll and also
share the results with you
folks uh I can see that we have
gotten uh 72% of the votes for I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and uh 33% of
the V for I can't find a program with
with a fully comprehensive curriculum
and 33% of the votes also for my worst
schedule vote along the for Learning and
18% votes for for I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos so thank
you so much for sharing that with us
this definitely gives us an
understanding on what exactly is
stopping you uh from becoming animl
expert so now let's move on uh to the
program introduction here so uh the the
program by I comp uh professional
certificate course in a machine learning
uh comes with a comprehensive and
Industry align learning path uh you also
get access to in uh Hands-On Labs uh
projects for practical experience uh
we'll be talking more about that in a
slides and all online virtual classrooms
so these are not pre-recorded videos we
actually have online virtual classrooms
with live Feer and instructor
interaction and the program duration for
uh the professional certificate course
in I machine learning is uh 11 months
and you can just complete it by giving
10 to 15 hours per week so I saw working
a lot of working professionals who have
joined us so this basically makes it
very flexible to fit your schedule in
case this this is something you're
planning to take up by ID Kut here and
and uh at the end of it all you'll be
getting a program completion certificate
from En ICT Academy I Cano as you can
see on the screen here which is for the
professional certificate course in Ai
and machine learning and also exposure
to latest trends like generative AI
prompt engineering Char GPT and much
more which we be talking about handsome
projects integrate Labs including a
Capstone project which we'll be talking
about as well master classes delivered
by distinguished IAT con faulty so a lot
more uh which is
uh ahead we'll be talking more about
that so let's uh discuss how this
program builds your aim skills step by
step so as you can see here the steps
here so I can you take us through these
steps here sure so once you start uh
this particular program you will have
your
induction and then you start with the
mathematics and uh statistics essential
plus programming refresher which is very
important because what I have seen over
the period of time when people start
learning a a ml they directly jump to
the algorithm they start thinking that
that if they know the algorithm that's
sufficient but what they do not
understand that the solid foundation is
very important if you want to eventually
become a data scientist or or probably
ml engineer or or even AI architect for
that matter so this particular uh
starting point is where you you get the
idea about different mathematical
Concepts which is very important uh to
uh from from from ml perspective and and
even the statistical Essentials which is
very very important to understand some
of the statistical terms which are used
in in ml domain then programming
refresher gives you a a good foundation
in how how python works and U overall
what's programming and then what are the
basics of python that's covered over
there so that tomorrow when you're using
python as a platform for for your
machine learning job you will be well
accustomed with with writing codes then
you have have applied data science with
python where we start with the working
with data in Python and we are preparing
data for for your algorithms so here we
deal with with the
basic feature engineering that that
you're supposed to know you should know
uh or data transformation that you
should know or probably some data com
com uh compression techniques which will
be very helpful in in building more
robust model so here you are you you you
taught some some statistical methods
some concept ceps which will be very
essential in in doing machine learning
project and that will be dealt with
python then once you are ready with with
working with the data where you can you
can you can uh convert from one format
to another which is suitable for for
machine learning then we move
to uh machine learning algorithms and we
talk about uh different algorithms which
are there like supervised and
unsupervised to start with at a very
broad level and then within each
framework what all algorithms are there
how do they work what's the mathematics
behind it and how do you implement on a
data set and what are the challenges you
might you might face on those algorithms
and how do you overcome that and one
very important part about each of these
algorithm that people try people
generally o Overlook is how do you
fine-tune the model so it will be
focusing on all these areas once you're
done with entire machine learning you'll
move to deep learning with Keras and
tensor flow it focuses
upon it focuses upon deep learning
algorithms which is primarily based on
neural network so how does a neural
network work and again how does how does
a math work behind behind each neural
network and then Implement on some
real-time problem how does it work
entirely and you will also learn how to
fine-tune neural networks and there are
different types of neural networks also
you have basic neural networks you have
convolutional neural network Rec neural
network you have some unsupervised
learning also within within uh deep
learning framework like uh Auto encoders
and all so all that will be taught to
you then you will move to Essentials of
generative AI prompt engineering and
chat GPT which has become a very hot
topic these days so you'll be given a
good overview of what are generative Ai
and how how how they are getting
utilized what are the applications of it
what is prompt engineering and how you
can uh get get better at prompting and
then chat GPT how does it work and how
you can utilize it and once this is
entirely done there'll be a Capstone
project which focuses upon testing your
knowledge on all these Concepts that you
have gone through so this is a very
comprehensive project which test your
understanding on on very basics of of of
ml projects and even to the advanced
level so it might focus upon U your your
strategy to handle missing data which is
a very very common problem to a problem
where you have overfitted model and you
need to find unit further so something
like that what what that's what will be
in Capstone project and in addition to
that you will have your electives as
well where you can opt for reinforcement
learning Advanced deep learning computer
vision NLP and there will be master
classes as well so this is what the
program
is uh thank you so much amindra for
taking us through these steps here of
the program also I think you already
mentioned about the electives here so
elective come as a part of the program
uh they are optional so uh we don't
charge anything extra for that it is up
to you if you want to take up these
amazing electives which cover the
program here so we are getting a lot of
interesting questions in the Q&A box
here and also as we live on our YouTube
channel as well uh we are getting few
questions from there as well we'll be
taking those questions uh pretty soon uh
so uh now let's talk about how you can
master in demand tools libraries and
platforms as well by uh this program by
IG uh now related to this actually we
have gotten a question here as well uh
on the Q&A box let
me let me just quickly
check uh this is from gka here amendra
uh in the Q&A box for aaml also is the
focus still on data structures and good
coding skills is what gtia is asking
come again what did you say uh for AIML
uh also is the focus still on data
structures and good coding
skills see good coding skills if you say
it's required because uh if I want to
build a model I need to rely on coding
now the good coding skill set so-called
that you're talking about will be very
useful when you have when you have to
work on on data preparation part your
data integration part and
and if you want to Simply experiment
with the ml model that's a separate
thing all together where data has been
provided to you and you simply taking
that neat and clean data and pushing
into a machine learning algorithm but
that doesn't happen so when you're
starting your your your career you'll
have to do you you have to get your
hands dirty and that's where the coding
skill is important now second part is
when you're deploying your your your
model so deployment is also have become
pretty important these days not only we
want to build we want to build applic
which is leveraging AIML Concepts and
there you need to create certain such
such such deployments which will cater
different kinds of request it should
have some fail over option it will have
uh some error handling options and all
so that's where the coding will come
very handy but having said that uh do
not think of you as as a working as a
python developer or as a as any any
programming developer basically you need
to learn that from from M Ai and ml
angle so as long as you are you good at
that that's
sufficient uh thank you so much for
answering that amendra uh also just one
more question before we cover even the
tools and platforms which will be in
demand I'm just sharing that with you on
the chart here because there are plenty
of question in the Q&A box it will be
hard to find so very similar to what
we're going to cover uh so Shin is
asking what all technical knowledge does
an interviewer seek in the fresh resumes
so now as we're talking about technical
knowledge tools and platforms do come in
that as well right that's correct so as
a fresher you are saying
right yes as a fresher uh as a fresher
if you ask me I would say uh your
Proficiency in in in uh commonly used
language in AIML it could be python it
could be R so understanding some basic
data structures and algorithms that's
what I would look into it that's what
generally people look and uh then they
will look your mathematics and
statistics Foundation how how how good
you are in in those terms so it could be
say some linear algebra calculus
probability understanding of statistical
Concepts essential for data analysis and
machine learning and uh then uh uh your
your your Proficiency in machine
learning fundamentals as well so
knowledge of basic machine learning
algorithms their applications
familiarity with supervised unsupervised
learning regression classification
clustering then take the same thing to
deep learning Concepts like awareness of
deep learning Concepts including your
neural networks your CNN RNN then uh uh
data handling and and pre-processing
techniques so ability to clean
pre-processed data for analysis and
modeling experience with data wrangling
and feature engineering so those those
things you should be very good at and
then you should also be aware of some
some Frameworks and libraries like it
could be say tensorflow Keras py psychic
learn okay and and if you can if you can
you can if you can get some
understanding on cloud computing that
will be little pretty good pretty good
and then not to forget uh moving towards
uh uh mlops so that's where your your
versioning will come into the picture so
your Version Control you can use Packy
DM you can use ml flow you can use Q
flow all that but that would be probably
a tad advance for for a fresher but if
you want to go into that particular
direction you can acquire knowledge on
that as
well uh thank you so much amendra for
answering a few questions here and also
covering the in demand tools and
libraries and platforms uh which is
program by it C covers Also let's talk
about the projects here with real
business application and also following
up with the capston project as well so
now for that also uh I can see one
interesting question here I'll just
share it with you on the chat here uh I
think it
requires knowledge about the project
here so let me just quickly check as
there are so many
questions huh this is I think I can see
not the name is not visible uh please
let me know what is your name here so uh
says that being an automotive designer
I'm switching career i' what steps to
take regarding projects to ensure quick
transition and utilizing my experience
as well as this program covers so many
industry based projects and also a
Capstone work you know you can choose to
work from uh what would you reply uh to
the answer here okay so transitioning
from a career as an automative designer
to a field like a ml involves leveraging
your existing skills and and and getting
new ones relevant to the Target industry
so what you can do you can identify some
transferable skills like like you you
might be very you might have a creative
problem solving so highlight experience
in Creative problem solving uh which you
have which you have used in your your
existing uh in in in your past
organizations and then uh you can talk
about uh uh you have a you have
a uh skill of attention to details like
like something like that you can talk
about where you can you can emphasize
your attention to detail crucial for
data pre-processing and model refinement
in AIML something like and then you
should learn AIML fundamentals uh you
you should enroll for a course which is
little comprehensive gives you not only
about the Core Concepts about AIML but
it should also focus upon some handson
and that's the one what what we are
offering over here it it talks about uh
not only in terms of dealing with the
concepts but you actually go to the lab
and there you solve a problem so that
that will give you a lot of confidence
and then you can select some relevant
projects also which can combine your
your design skills with AI uh design
skills in a sense of automative that
you're talking about and where you can
create some AI driven prototypes you can
start thinking in that line probably you
can talk about it this is the idea it
came to you and probably you want to
explore in future when you when you're
on the interview table which will give
the idea that you are able to map uh how
AI is going to going to work in in a
particular domain and then uh you can
also think from and I'm giving you
answers from your background perspective
so so computer vision for for design
analysis so you can develop a project
using computer vision to analyze Design
Elements such as evaluating user
preferences based on images or or
automating design feature
extractions okay so all all those
projects also you can start thinking
that this these are these are the kind
of things probably you can work upon in
future or probably you can pick up some
data you can practice DO some Hands-On
exp uh uh practice the more you do the
better and uh you'll be good to start
looking for a job then once you finish
all this don't forget to build your
portfolio which showcases all the
projects that you have done it could be
your personal projects it could be
something that you have done in the in
the in the in the company okay so that's
how you should go
about uh thank you so much amendra for
answering the question please do let us
know if you have any followup questions
for here as am mentioned the projects
are so important for someone who does
not have an experience in IML uh the
program by it K here which is the
professional certificate course in IML
uh covers these uh basically projects
with real business applications uh as
you can see retail production bfsi and
many more and also a caption project to
work on which you can showcase to your
future employees uh which is very much
effective uh when you can mimic real
life business scenarios for True
experience which you can show in your
portfolio you get to choose from one of
the SE out of several projects basically
from this program which you get to work
on once you're done with your program
here and also U basically caption
projects are rigorous in nature and
provide great examples of your work for
your portfolio resume in case you're
struggling with your project you can
definitely cover through this program as
well so uh am just one question you have
given us the importance of how important
having a project is uh here the program
covers a caption one as well so
how important a cap project is as well
you know like you get to choose from
several domains here uh to basically add
cap project to your portfolio so apart
from all the projects you already have
worked on uh to this program but how
does a caption work project help you
showcase your true experience in when
you don't have any inl and you're coming
coming from completely different field
well I'll tell you from it has a twofold
impact one is that uh you get a lot of
confidence after doing it because you
this is the these these projects are
quite comprehensive and it tests your
knowledge at different level right from
basic data preparation to at advanc
level of of model building so it gives
you a lot of confidence once you solve
it because uh uh you you get to work on
all the integrities of of data
preparation feature engineering data
transformation then then then building
the model within building the model
framework itself you're trying different
experiments over there and then
eventually you're evaluating and
deciding that this model is good or bad
so it gives you a lot of confidence and
then second thing is is that you can
showcase that as your as a project that
you have done because of in-depth
analysis you have gone through you can
actually write about it and not only you
can write about it nicely when when it
comes to the interview you can explain
them that what you have done because you
have done it on your own so I'm saying
twofold impact a you get lot of uh lot
of confidence after doing it B it
showcase that you have work worked on a
project and you can explain in a nicely
nice manner the way I explained to you
initially when we were talking about how
to talk about project so it gives you a
hands-on experience it gives you a lot
of confidence it showcase uh on on on
your resume that you have worked on
projects you have gone in detail and
that's something is what interview is
looking
for definitely agree uh thank you so
much uh for answering that as well uh so
we have talked about the skills here we
have talked about the career parts we
talked about about what this program
covers as well let's talk about the
eligibility and the prequisites as well
of this program so you uh need to have
prior knowledge or experience in
programming and Mathematics a bachelor's
degree with an average of 50% or higher
marks is required and two plus years of
formal work experience is preferred not
compulsory but preferred now um I think
as we can see that it says that we need
to have Bri knowledge or experience in
programming and Mathematics what kind of
experience or uh
basically knowledge are we expecting uh
basically aspiring students uh to
basically have before they take up this
program well if if they want to uh go
through some Basics I would strongly
recommend go through basics of
statistics and and your mathematic
mathematics within mathematics you can
pick up linear algebra and calculus
although we do a refresher on that but
still if you want to start with it
that's what you can do so basic algebra
calculus
statistical techniques not techniques
entirely but some basics of Statistics
like what is a dispersion or some mean
median mode that you talk about very
basic and then if you can if if you can
go through some of the programming uh
Basics also that will be very useful so
that's something kind of prerequisite
you can you can
cover thank you so much amra for
clearing that up so uh and also we have
global leaders as program uh advisers as
well uh so here uh Prof Professor am K
who's the uh basically uh the program
director of Department of computer and
science engineering I kanur make sure
that simply and basically is delivery to
delivering as per standards of I Cano
here and also uh as we move on uh as we
have talked about uh so much about the
careers and the skills which will be in
demand will be in demand in in 2024 and
also in the future as well and we have
talked about how this program uh
basically builds your skills step by
step and also the industry based
handsone projects you get to work on
through this I program by I Kor here and
also caption project you can can choose
from from several projects you can add
to your portfolio which definitely will
help you giving you that experience of
having a realtime working experience
which you can showcase to your future
employees so uh we we would love to know
are you interested in enrolling in into
the professional certificate program inl
by ID Caro you can see a quick poll
launched on the screen here uh which
says what you like to enroll in the
program you can select the option yes to
show interest and I'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps of the
program a very quick overview how how to
enroll and what are the upcoming cohorts
and also uh the program fee of uh this
program as well by it
kpur also folks who are concerned that I
can't join immediately I have not
planned this yet so that's totally okay
we have many cours throughout the year
in the upcoming new year and I will be
asking you that as well like you know
just to get a ballp figure so we will
understand when to basically reach out
to you with the admission details so as
I'm speaking I am seeing a lot of
interest towards enrollment into the ID
CST professional certificate program in
a so that's good uh I would uh give like
I think 10 to 15 seconds more for the
few for few of the folks who are still
basically responding for the poll here
take your time uh we have 10 15 seconds
more uh as we basically uh you know move
on to the enrollment steps of the
program here uh the shali I'll be
sharing that the program fee as well and
Libya as well I'll be sharing that in
the upcoming slide please don't
worry welcome to sh uh also uh we
managed to answer a lot of your
questions as promise throughout the
session uh we have exceeded by few
minutes I hope that's okay
mendra that's fine not a problem sure
sure meanwhile uh maybe you can browse
through the questions here and if you
find some time you can basically answer
them as well as we have already out of
time um fine folks I think uh I see that
folks are still responding for the poll
here I think I'll just give five more
seconds so last five seconds for uh to
letting us know through this poll here
are you interested in enrolling into the
professional certificate program inl by
it Cano you can see a quick poll on your
screen which is launched uh where you
can share your interest towards
enrollment by selecting yes in this poll
here uh which I see a lot of you have
basically opted for that's great we'll
be taking you through the enrollment
step of the program pretty soon and uh
just giving you uh much more details
about the program which we have covered
so
far awesome last five seconds folks for
the poll which you can see on your
screen you can share your interest there
uh are you interested in rolling into
the professional certificate program inl
by I Cano here so five 4 3 2 one let me
quickly end the poll thank you so much
uh for sharing your response for this
poll now for the folks which I saw a lot
of you have shared interest in
enrollment to the it Kos professional
certificate program in a IML let me
quickly take you through the enrollment
step and the program schedule as well so
uh so the learning concept from Simply
will be reaching out to you with
admissions detail uh these are the three
simple easy steps they'll be basically
uh letting you follow uh and guiding you
as well so you need to basically submit
an application to us ask us.net uh and
then your application will be going for
review will be reviewed by it Cil and
Bas on that you'll be getting admissions
offer letter from SAR learly consultant
and obviously we'll be getting you
giving you a much more detailed walk
through of the program as well if you
need assistance that is something I'll
be asking you towards the end also the
enrollment schedule and the program fee
so the classes will be starting the this
is the immediate C the class classes
will be starting on 20th Chan 2024 next
year and the deduction for this
particular cohort will be on 3rd genan
2024 uh also the program fee which a lot
of you asked is
13,400 uh INR rupees including taxes and
also I think someone did ask that if
there are any Emi options available uh
so we do have that and it is available
for as low as
5,220 uh rupees per month uh if you have
any questions you can always reach out
to us at ask us at s.net I'll share that
email ID uh in sometime and also just to
let you know we have very limited
cohorts uh and also we take very limited
folks per cohart as well in order to
make sure that you're getting all the
attention that is required when you're
taking of this program um also moving on
uh as I mentioned earlier we would love
to know how soon do you plan to enroll
into the program basically you can see a
quick pole Lacher new screen with this
is for the folks who have shared
interest in enrollment which is a lot of
you uh so please do uh respond to this
poll and let us know how soon do you
plan to enroll the immediate uh cohort
which is the first option which I have
already told you which is starting on uh
Jan uh 24th and uh last three options
are within 3 months 6 months and more
than six months from now these are the
ones which you feel like okay I'm not
sure exactly when to start but you do
have interest uh in basically uh joining
so am meanwhile while they are voting
for this poll here thank you so much for
your time uh thank you for an amazing
interesting another interview with
master class uh and it's always a
pleasure to have you would you like to
say something to the audience before you
leave thanks Rasha I would just say that
uh that once you have once you have
joined this
particular webinar it it seems that you
have interest inl I'll strongly
recommend that pursue this particular
field it's going to give you lot of uh
advantage in coming years so on that
note I'll stop here and I'll sign off
and probably I'll see you some of you in
in some other Forum thank you guys sure
sure thank you so much am thank you have
a good night thank you
night okay uh folks one last P for you
for you as well you can see a quick poll
on your screen uh do you need assistance
in enrolling into the IT campus
professional certificate program in AML
you can uh just uh let us know through
this PO here and also for you folks uh
you have been an amazing audience and a
very active one with all the engagement
we have gotten and amazing responses
from your folks it's always good to see
you uh thank you so much I see a lot of
thank yous coming in on the chat here uh
thank you so much and for the folks
which is a lot of you who have basically
shared interest towards enrollment uh
into the ID campus program we would love
to see you in upcoming cohorts next year
and uh I I wish you for all the best for
the career paths you are aspiring for
which you have shared with us warmly so
thank you so much uh thank you everyone
uh I see a lot of thank you coming on
the chat
here uh we actually will be coming up
with a lot of new uh master classes in
the next year through these webinars we
do so you can look forward to a lot of
them just like the interview by Master
Class one thank you so much thank you
thank you everyone uh it's always great
to have you uh we actually have one last
webinar tomorrow in case you want to
attend I just share the basically link
to webinars here you can check it out in
case you want to basically register for
it you can basically learn grow uh from
uh the excitement of master classes
which we do so we have one last webinar
tomorrow for basically this year we'll
be closing early because uh holiday
season ahead right New Year and
Christmas right so uh you can check out
here we have a very interesting session
on cyber security guys so let me do one
thing let me just show it to you only so
we have a very interesting session on
cyber security and we have a very
amazing speaker expert uh speaker Paris
aora who basically works at Microsoft
uh as a cyber security expert and uh in
case you exploring and basically want to
know more about cyber security uh we can
change we can basically uh get to know
what exactly is happening cyber security
and what why exactly you will be
demanded 2024 you can uh go and register
using this link here so when you click
on this link this particular planning
page will be opening up while by simply
done and uh tomorrow it is in the same
time MPN and you can register it by just
clicking on register here and putting
down a few details which is required for
registering so this is again like an
interesting one uh this is the last one
of this year and uh this is something
very interesting lined up tomorrow so
folks who are also interested in EML I'm
pretty sure you would love to explore
cyber security as well and uh you can
definitely ask questions of II and cyber
security as well because we actually
have those career paths which are
actually a combo ofl and cyber security
in Dand which will be talking about
tomorrow as well so uh please do check
it out and again like as I said lovely
to see you folks uh and lovely to have
you folks you have been an amazing
audience thank you so much folks have a
good night uh and good evening wherever
you're joining us from thank you thank
you folks thank you thank you everyone
see you tomorrow in case you're joining